hello everyone a lot of you've been
asking me to show some of my games and
well today the Croatian National League
started and my chess club went to play
another chess club and I played the
onboard one I played against the
candidate master and I checked some of
his games online and while I saw that he
doesn't really lose a lot of games but
he I saw that the games he did lose with
the white pieces were against the Kings
Indian defense and well so of course I
checked out some of Nakamura's games in
the Kings Indian and well I thought I'd
prepared pretty good but it's not it's
not the game itself I mean I was pretty
satisfied with the way I played I just
well didn't really like the way the game
ended but you'll see what I mean as the
quote above the board illustrates it
pretty well so my opponent is white and
he plays c4 I go Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 g6 d4 Bishop to g7 e4 and d6 saw the
standard King Indian defense variation
Knight to f3 and here I castled Bishop
to e2 and here Knight B to d7 is a more
standard more or maybe e5 but I play
Knight to c6 as a lot of players didn't
seem to well grasp this position well my
opponent played the d5 and I retreated
with the knight Knight to be 8 he played
castles and here I played e5 and now I
don't mind if he captures he captured a
D captures an e6 on Poisson I will
develop my bishop and I don't mind this
for black some instead he played Bishop
to g5 and here I thought well I mean ok
there's a bishop in g5 so I played h6 I
want to know what his intentions are
with his dark squared bishop and well he
played Bishop to h4 maybe Bishop to e3
was a better idea here but he went to
Bishop to h4 and I immediately pushed to
g5 as I had a pretty good idea what my
plan was here
he played Bishop to g3 and I played
Knight to age 5
my idea isn't to capture this dark
square bishop as this dark square bishop
isn't really doing anything it's just
hitting my 'if I've borne em idea was
actually to place the knight on f4 and
if he ever captures the knight now then
I can play it captures on f4 and my dark
square Bishop comes alive and well if he
doesn't really have any good discoveries
what is night so his bishop would be
attacking my knight whatever he captures
here or here or whatever he plays I
simply capture the bishop and I also
have a tempo on his rook so that's not
really an option so he played Knights to
d2 and now he opened up the attack on my
knight and aged five and I went Knight
to f4 and like I said I do enjoy my
night being on f4 if he ever captures
that I'll simply recapture here and my
bishop comes alive so he played Bishop
to g4 here he wants me to capture on g4
so he could play Queen captures and g4
and this would be a very nice well a
very nice square for his queen but I
actually played Knight to d7 now with
ideas of well good ideas of Knight to f6
so if he captures my bishop on c8 I
capture with my queen and c8 so I can
get my Queen into the game as well here
he played b4 and in this position I
played a5 I want to break up this
massive bone structure and probably best
for white here would be to push b5
although this isn't really a move you
want to make as white as you do a lot of
moves like Knight to c5 but my opponent
played a three here and this a3 is
actually a blunder but I didn't take
advantage of this as it was a kind of a
subtle blunder i I was I was really
looking how to get how to make my Bishop
become alive but the idea is after a3 I
do have this move h5 and this is well
this is troublesome for white if he
captures the pawn Bishop captures on h5
then I seem to play a capture some
before and this is what a tactic that a
a capture some before rook captures only
one Queen captures anyone and now this
Bishop on h5 is hanging so after this h5
move he would well you would probably
have to
play something like Bishop to f5 which
kind of gives me a beautiful pawn chain
here and then I could push h4 or or
capture my night here on d7 but this
would be excellent as I would have the
bishop pair but I didn't see this h5
idea so after a three
I played Knight to f6 which was my
original idea
now I'm attacking this Bishop twice so
he captures Bishop captures on c8 Queen
captures on c8 and he plays Knight to b3
now attacking this a a five point I have
so I capture he captures and I play rook
captures on a one we captures anyone and
well I had a lot of ideas here I in the
game I played h5 which I thought it was
a pretty good move threatening gauge for
if he wants to get his Bishop out of the
way he will have to weaken his King
position but I was also thinking
thinking about a move like Knight
captures on e4
but I didn't really I didn't really want
to spend too much time calculating this
my idea was after something like Knight
captures on e on e for I could play it
nice to e to check and after King to h1
I could play something like f5 and I
thought okay after he moves his Knight
I'll just play f4 and I win the piece
back but here there were a lot of
options for white so I didn't really I
didn't really go into this and well the
engine doesn't like this for black so
maybe it's good I haven't played this
but it only it it gives the advantage of
a pawn to white so maybe I could have
played this but okay after this Queen
captures rook on a1 I played h5
threatening h4 and here he played the
hip here he played f3 kind of making
room for his bishop but after I continue
with my plan I played h4 if play
something like Bishop to f2 or Bishop to
e1
I do have this Knights to d3 move with
an attack on his dark square Bishop and
also attacking this b4 pawn so here
after h4 he captured it Bishop captures
on f4 e captures on f4 and he played
Queen Queen to a7 with ideas of what
Knight to a5 to it
my b7 pawn and well if I play something
like b6 then night to c5 maybe but he
does have this problem of my discovery
here if my knight ever moves dis almonds
up the attack on this knight on c3 and
well the engine is giving here Knight to
g4 as a move sort of as now my bishop is
attacking the knight on c3 and after
this is dealt with while he will either
capture F captures my knight and g3 or
he will move the knight and then I can
play maybe nights the e3 but I didn't
know if after for example if I play
Knight g4 after night 2 d1 what was the
idea here I mean night to e3 doesn't
really achieve anything simply playing
Knight to e5 maybe improving the
position of the night but okay I didn't
go for this after Quinte 7 I played h3 I
already had upon on h4 so when I play
pawn to h3 and break break open his King
he played g3 and I played F captures ng
3h capture some g3 and now Knight to h5
and a while now I'm attacking the g3
pawn and also this knight on c3 with my
bishop so he played night 3 2 this is
the best move as it prevents both
threats denied also defends on g3 and
well here after thinking for a couple of
minutes
I played f5 and I thought that was a
good move I didn't really see any good
moves for him as well I am threatening
he captures F captures any 4 here
opening up my rook so he played a queen
to e3 and this is the strongest move the
engine is recommending and well I had a
lot of ideas here my initial idea as I
was going towards this position was to
actually play a knight the g3 here so
after he captures I just push f4 but
then he has this Queen to F to move and
after I capture Queen captures I didn't
really see if I had anything here I mean
okay his King gets kind of loose but so
is mine I mean this g5 point of mine
isn't really the best poem
so after this Queen to e3 move I didn't
go for Knight captures and g3
but I also had ideas of f4 so maybe G
captures a knife or a knife captures on
f4 and on knife captured on f4 and rook
captures on f4 but again I didn't see I
had anything good here
oh and well the engine the engine agrees
with me so after the screen - III move I
played Queen to d8 now defending my g5
pawn and I played this with a with a
kind of a risk a risky tactic as I
didn't really have time to calculate it
all out I'm giving up my pawn here
because he played he captures on F on f5
and of course if I capture with my rook
then G 4 and he wins a piece but this
was my idea I played rook to e8
attacking the Queen he played Queen to
f2 and now comes my idea into play I
played rukka captures I need to
sacrificing the exchange he played Queen
captures I need to and now I can't
really go for Knights capture sin g3 yet
attacking the Queen and the rook because
he has this Intermezzo a queen Queen to
e6 check and after my King moves
he will then move the rook but what what
my idea was that after Queen captures
and he - I played Bishop to e5 not
allowing him to play Queen to e6 check
but I'm also attacking this g3 pawn here
and well he doesn't really have a way of
permit preventing me from capturing it
but at this moment he was already down
to maybe 2 minutes on the clock so I
didn't really feel too bad about giving
up the exchange so he played f4 and this
wasn't really a great move as I as I was
hoping for him to do this
I put not okay he's attacking my Bishop
here and also my knight here with the
Queen but I have Knight captures an g3
and now I'm attacking his Queen his rook
and also his queen cannot go to h5 but I
also knew that he his queen couldn't
could never go to g4 if he played the
Queen to g4 I had h2 and this is a
winning move he can't really capture the
pawn hook because I will grab the
Rockwood check so after King to g2
I have knife captures on f1 and now well
he can't capture the night because I
will Queen the pawn but he can't
captured my bishop as well if he
captures my bishop he gets Knights the
e3 for King the king and the Queen
so after this Knight captures ng3 he
found the best move he played the Queen
to h2 and now I have to grab the rope
I've played Knight captures the rook on
f1 he played the King captures rook or
Knight and f1 and I played Bishop
captures and f4 attacking his queen and
he played the Queen captures on h3 and
okay we both have four pawns but I have
a bishop against his night and I was I
was sure this was a winning and I played
Queen to f6 here which is the strongest
move I'm well protecting everything here
I'm not allowing his Knight into the
game via Knight to g4 and also I'm
forcing his Queen to keep keep an eye on
this f5 pawn because if the Queen moves
I'll just grab it so he played Queen to
d3 now guarding the pawn from d3 and
also not preparing to get his knight
into the game with Knight to the to d4 I
didn't want to allow this so I played
Bishop to e5 not allowing the knight in
and he played a King to g2 and I
immediately played a g4 here as now my
pawn is covering f3 and h3 and the
bishop is guarding g3 so I thought this
was pretty good for me and maybe maybe I
even have some mating ideas here he
played a knight to d2 and I played Queen
to h4 now threatening ideas like Queen
to h2 check so he stopped this Knight 2
f1 and here I just well there really
isn't a way for me to continue the
attack so I played King to f7 I want to
improve my position and get my king to
f6 so after I decided what to do here my
king will be free to capture this F pawn
he played c5 and of course I ignored
this this doesn't really threaten
anything so I played King to f6 and he
played c6 and okay I play b6 b5 was even
better but I was already low on time so
I didn't even consider b5 he played b5
himself and it's my move now
and well I didn't really find a good
move to play here I mean I did find a
good move it's a winning move but
although the engine is recommending
Queen to h6 I I played Quint h3 check
and I went for the exchange of Queens
because well after ping captures on h3g
capture screen captures I played King
captures on f5 and I mean his King is so
far away I'm just gonna gobble up all
these pawns and here he played Knights
to d2 and not allowing my king to go to
e4 and well this is actually the moment
where I blunder the game because this is
a this is a completely winning position
but I decided to play Bishop to Bishop
to c3 now attacking his knight in this
position I didn't really even look at my
game anymore I thought of course this is
completely winning I was looking at the
other games my teammates were playing
and I thought well I mean there is no
way this isn't winning I mean look at
this King on h3 and I played Bishop the
c3 and he played Knight to c4 and here I
knew I know what his idea was he wanted
to capture either my heater my D pawn or
my be pawn and then if I recapture he
can push his C pawn and still I was I
was you know I wasn't really sure if
this is a if this is a draw so I play
King to e4 and after he captured Knight
captures with check I can't recapture
the night because then B the B the C
pawn is going forward so I played King
Carter's on d5 and here he played a
Knight to c8 and well as you can see
this is a completely drawn drawn ending
because he will play nice to a7 at some
point for example I can play King to c5
and night to a7 and his Knight is not
protecting both of these these pawns the
b-pawn and the C pawn and they're both
on light squares my bishop is useless
here and
I can never get in closer with my king
because this point this be point is
protecting a sixth and the world the
knight is protecting a c8 so I can't go
to challenge this night and I can't
attack these pawns so this was the
critical moment of the endgame when he
played this night the d2 move
I played Bishop to c3 but I should what
I should have played was simply Bishop
to d4 and it's a it's really a small
difference I mean now now I've read this
he five square for making so I can grab
the pawn this way but now if he plays
Knight to c4 this this move doesn't
really do anything because I play Knight
to Bishop to c5 and now he can't capture
any of these pawns because the bishop
will capture the night so yeah after
Knight - D - like I said this is the
critical position and well this is where
I blundered the game the game ended in a
draw but it was a winning position for
me so yeah don't don't do this if you if
you know I never really start
celebrating my win before I actually won
the game but here I didn't think white
had any chances of drawing this so so
yeah I did make that mistake that I
always say that I never will make and
you know this this can be a lesson for
you not to do something like this you
know even if you're winning do check the
winning move as I did have well I did
have about five minutes here around the
clock
I could have checked for a better move
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to think they
have a living for a contribution to my
channel I really appreciate it thank you
lot sir and yeah as usual you can check
through my previous videos here and
that's it thank you for watching I will
see you soon